the Amazon hash at war is ongoing and
your published by her shed and you you
and your books kind of got caught in the
middle David and Goliath right now on
sale on Amazon 26 dollars and ten cents
it's much cheaper on Barnes and Noble
how are you feeling about this right now
well yes no it's cost me a lot of money
that's for sure
I mean it's it breaks my heart a little
I had thought of Amazon as in
partnership with writers and for a
company to try and make a business point
by turning its back on you know I have I
have sold through Amazon millions of
books I have contributed mightily to
their bottom line I would have thought
they would see me as an asset I have
brought people me and other writers have
brought people to their site in droves
and now they've you know turned on us I
mean it as a is a to say the least a
puzzling strategy for a business to turn
on its assets and I would love to have a
conversation with Jeff Bezos about you
know the the self-destructive nature of
this particular strategy amazon is
arguing that books must be cheaper in
this environment where there are so many
media distractions have any sympathy for
their argument complete sympathy for it
I just don't understand about I why in
order to get to that preferred outcome
they have chosen to screw over there the
people who are bringing who bringing
revenue to their business and customers
to their site I mean it just it's like
sure let's have a conversation about
what the right price of a book is but
along the way I mean in order to have
this conversation Amazon is raising the
price of my book and spending several
weeks to delivering it so it's like it's
a very odd way to get to that preferred
outcome